[MUSIC]
Loser, retarded,
fabulous.
Bullying, definitely not
a topic back in the 90s.
Not a topic back in the 90s
in Brazil where I grew up.
But violence in this call was
a reality for many of us.
I remember a classmate with a lisp.
He couldn't talk pronounce a single
ward without being mocked.
I remember the cross eyed girl from
the school bus, who was always alone.
Ignore by the other girls.
In the yard there was always
someone who was too short,
too fat, too tall too skinny too,
something that had to be pointed out.
Me, I was too soft, too gentle,
not aggressive enough for a boy.
I didn't know what was
gay at the age of seven.
But bullying was already a daily
tasks of endurance for me.
I remember entering the school in fear,
never knowing when
the insults would start.
I remember spending entire school
breaks locked in restrooms to
protect myself from punches.
But when punches happen,
I was the one sent to
the principal's office.
I still feel my jaws burning and
tightening while I
tried as much as I could
to hold back my tears.
Boys don't cry.
Be a man Ricardo.
What that was supposed to mean?
Wasn't I a man?
>> [LAUGH]
>> When good friends tried to defend me
against bullies,
they incorrectly claimed things like stop.
He's not gay.
Of course I was happy to have
someone watching my back but
when I finally realized that actually,
I was gay.
The whole thing made me feel embarrassed,
lonely, ashamed.
My identity was denied even by those who
in theory were on my side, my friends.
Back home.
The fear of disappointing
my parents kept me quiet.
How could mommy and
daddy be proud of a fag?
Because it was different,
I blamed myself for being bullied.
I was convinced that I didn't
deserve a place in the world.
Probably leave from the daily
bullying at school,
I turned myself to the make
believe world of movies.
Thank God I had movies.
Edward Scissorhands and Forrest Gump
proved that outliers could also thrive.
Better education,
Brokeback Mountain, portrayal larger
visions of love encouraged me
to stand tall no matter what.
I had to find a way to be happy.
Here I am.
Cinema changed my life through
my favorite characters.
I live vicariously and
learn how to overcome prejudice.
When it came time to choose
a career go to the university.
I wanted to help our struggling teenagers
to find comfort and acceptance.
I decided to do to cinema,
went to film school and
soon became an international sales agent.
My job was selling films
to tactical distributors,
TV channels and
streaming platforms across the world.
By negotiating film rights, I could
choose what people would watch next.
Embracing diversity I
couldn't give a voice for
those who know fashion like me,
but also foster cultural exchange.
It's much easier to understand
another culture if we have seen its
people on the screen before, right?
I was happy to represent Rafiki
a queer coming of age from Kenya.
Where homosexuality is a civil crime or
bad outcome.
It's Baraka, a romantic comedy from Saudi
Arabia calling from freedom in the region.
I was proud of myself.
But as a professional
of the film industry,
I had to acknowledge how
problematic films could also be.
While cinema helped me and
many others to embrace our identities.
It also spread the stereotype
of masculinity that not
only shaped and
normalize my aggressors behaviors.
But also encouraged them to be violent and
cruel.
Think about our traditional heroes.
Batman, James Bond or
the killing machines from the 80s and
90s Rumble, Robocop, the Terminator.
Apart from sarcastic jokes
they don't talk much.
Never ask or answer questions but
nobody knows what's
going on in their heads but
all of a sudden it's violent so clock.
>> [LAUGH]
>> They express themselves
ascending doesn't show how?
Aster LA vista baby.
>> [LAUGH]
>> But wait, bad communication skills and
the tendency to solve
differences with violence?
Doesn't that sound like bullying?
Sometimes I wonder who may aggressors
back in school or victimizing today.
According to the statistics,
more than 85% of the homicides
in the US were committed by men.
And more than two thirds of the women
killed in the country were shot by
their husbands.
In cases of domestic violence instead of
encouraging boys should
be kind in vulnerable.
Hollywood has a stimulate them
to hone muscles in ninja skills.
Describing a toxic stereotype of
masculinity you pressure to conform
has prevented man from showing emotions
and forced them to forego empathy.
Year after year.
We have seen on the screen
the same old formulas.
But the Hollywood now
is investing diversity.
Here's the question,
keeping the same old models wouldn't
just perpetuate the same
old violence stereotypes?
White western man are no
longer the only ones around,
but violent characters
are still the coolest.
On the big screen.
The good news is that on smaller screens,
streaming platforms offered today
more than ever content from different
countries, communities and cultures.
We are a click away from films that depict
that convey different definitions of man.
Different kind of people and
different ways of living life.
Imagine if as a child, my colleagues and
I have had access to all these
different ways of living life.
We would probably feel less different,
less lonely.
I would feel the yes I was a man
a more soft and gentle one but
is to a man who deserved
a place in the world.
Durrett is in this call would accept not
only me, but the classmate to Felicity.
The crowds I had grow
from the school bus and
all the other kids in the yard
who were choose something.
We still have a long way
to go against more than
a century of oppressive
characters in films.
But the growing diversity on
the scream is a beacon of hope for
a more empathetic society.
As an audience,
I invite you today to be curious,
to explore new narratives and to make
space for people to be just different.
No violence of any kind is acceptable.
Let's make the world a more kind place,
not only for struggling kids,
but for all of us.
Thank you.
>> [APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC]